you know what wins you know what wins
you know what i trust let me tell you
what i trust i trust capitalism yeah let
me explain to what i mean by trust
capitalism here's how i trust capitalism
um people call out dana white well you
know let me tell you ufc this this this
is that what does they know why i say
why don't you go compete go do it start
your own ufc you can do it nobody holds
you back let me know i don't like joe
rogan's podcast he's wrong bro go start
your own podcast and you share your
thoughts i don't like the fact that you
talk about capitalism dude why don't you
go start own show and you talk about
anti-capitalism and see if there's an
argument i don't like the fact that this
so watch what happened elon musk buys
9.2 percent and everybody was like oh
it's just a passive passive passive
position right and i said it's not
passive a guy like that's never going to
do passive you know what news just came
out an hour ago elon musk joins
twitter's board of directors
teases significant improvements did you
see what elon tweeted yesterday did you
see what he along tweeted yeah go to
elon's tweet yesterday yeah the poll
corey long's tweet yesterday look what
elon tweeted this this is why you trust
capitalism and those who work in
government don't like capitalists right
because capitalists know how to fight
okay so watch this
look click on that do you want an edit
button on twitter you know what an edit
button is so you know how you got it on
instagram you got it on facebook you got
it everywhere yeah you see what you did
on the poll by the way what's that you
see how he spelled yes
that's funny yeah so so anyways he puts
do you uh uh do you want an edit button
what does this mean to you he's already
insinuating we're going to improve
twitter what does that edit button mean
to you use twitter a lot but who cares
the whole the whole premise behind it is
i'm here to improve and change things
with twitter that's all he's saying so
in hollywood go to hollywood
so you know people are like part of the
oh you cannot be on the inside and all
this stuff well this happened in high
school the guys that were the football
cool guys that you can't be on the
inside fast forward 10 years later the
guy that you didn't allow to get into
the inside is now running a company
called facebook uh and who are you now
you're still a waiter at that one place
well zuck won just so you know so
capitalism wins whoever's willing to
improve
and take things and the moment you
that's the biggest thing about
capitalism that sucks so
uh i was watching
uh batman this weekend my kids are into
this whole batman thing i watch the last
batman couldn't stand it but the kids
started wanting to watch batman begins
and i said okay fine so we're on
the third batman which is it the dark
knight rises you know that whole dark
night rises and there's a scene which is
incredible the scene is when he's in the
cave you know the cave when he's trying
to come out i don't know if you can you
pull up dark knight rises put the cave
and he's talking to this blind man have
you seen when he's talking to this blind
man this scene folks this scene is a
dark night rises it's going to give you
the chills here so
uh a blind man i'm going to read to you
what he says okay
so he's in there he's trying to climb
out of this cliff this uh what do you
call it this cave he can't get out okay
every time he tries to get out he can't
get out
he comes up he jumps up he falls down he
comes up he jumps up he falls down right
this whole thing
then one of the guys when he falls down
one of the man says why do you keep
trying you're not gonna make it
he says what do you mean i'm not gonna
make it he says you're not gonna make it
he says but the child made it he says
yeah but you're not the child he says
why not he says because the child didn't
live a life of luxuries you did
the child didn't grow up with everything
you did
the child had nothing to lose you did
and he goes and he says but i'm going to
make it so he comes up doing abs and
push-ups and all this stuff he goes
again there's a jump you got to make he
doesn't make it he falls down
then he drops and he sees this blind man
type in blind man that he's talking to
this blind man put blind man
yeah so then he sees this blind man that
click on that right there the one at the
top no no top left top left top left you
had it
top left right there go uh yeah right
there but not yeah put that scene right
there
so he's talking to this man and look
what the man says here's a script i'll
read it to you
he says to him
he says
you do not fear death
you think this makes you strong but it
makes you weak
he says what do you mean
he says how can you move faster than
possible
fight longer than possible without the
most powerful impulse of the spirit the
fear of death you don't fear death
because you know when you're like i
don't fear that i don't fear anything
bruce wayne says i do fear death
i fear dying in here
while my city burns
and there's no one to save it
then the blind man says
then make the climb he says how
he says as the child did without the
rope
then fear will find you again
and he makes this climb
and he jumps he says i'm not using the
rope he jumps he makes it he goes all
the way out then throws the rope and all
the people that are in prison come out
what's the moral the story the people in
hollywood
have had a rope
they've lived a life of luxuries yeah
and there's always going to be the
entrepreneur that has nothing to lose
the guy that's sitting there saying i
don't have the luxury of a rope i don't
have the luxury of a giffen or this
producer or that guy that's got my back
i'm gonna figure this thing out and then
what do you produce you produce a
netflix then when you produce a netflix
who blockbuster didn't want to buy for
50 million dollars what does netflix do
net every big hollywood producer goes to
sleep fearing netflix hulu amazon all of
these guys the game in hollywood has
completely changed a guy like me can say
kevin why don't we make a movie how much
of a budget do we need he says two
million dollars we make a movie we go
out and put it out there independently
not needing these big guys and that
thing can do 200 million dollars that's
right elon musk can go buy a twitter and
say i'm sorry guys you guys are bullying
and silencing and censorship no problem
i'm gonna buy your company that's why
you gotta trust capitalism and that's
why i think hollywood's not in the same
place because they can't play those
power plays they once could play due to
capitalism that's true and that is
always going to be true i mean if you
look at like atlanta started the studios
of atlanta vancouver and all these
places you know if you open up the tax
base you can get a lot of studios and
make a hollywood in atlanta you know
this is capitalism this is why this
country is the best country on the
planet because we allow that stuff and
yeah twitter obviously is going to
change and overnight
by a guy who's a billionaire
and he wants to change it okay well he's
going to change it
and that's what happens and that is the
beauty of being in this country and and
obviously the trajectory of all
companies they get fat and people get
fat and
and they start making mistakes you know
here's here's a that's one thing to
watch here's i make this prediction and
it's going to happen
guarantee
um
because you've never been wrong tom
jeremy go ahead but watch the headlines
the headlines on elon musk going forward
everything's gonna be negative they're
going to be ripping him in main street
media they're going to find flaws in him
i saw one the other day here is the
headline elon musk wants to kill baby
seals or something
i saw it on insider i mean so now that
he's on the inside and he's going to be
on the board of directors with twitter
they're going to go after him personally
you're going to see a ton of negativity
what do you think do you think there's a
possibility you know he gets comfortable
in the board of directors here in the
next few months maybe buys more stock
because he's not done right he's going
to buy more
how does he handle trump is he going to
say it's okay for him to come back
that's gonna come up at some point and
it's gonna be uh who makes those
decisions does the board make that
decision pat who's gonna end up making
that decision yeah i think so so so
that's that's the part where dorsey
is um getting a little bit more credit
now to say i'm not the one it's a board
that votes these types of things so
nobody knows where dorsey's vote was
some the people on the inside obviously
know and then he finally said yeah i
also voted for it that we got to get him
out right elon can get in there and say
no yeah we may want to change it but
remember he's only got one seat
he's only got one seat he doesn't have
the majority he only got one seat so he
can get in there and try to persuade
and say things but they can still say
no
and gradually what elon can do is one by
one by one by another three percent yes
by another two percent here by the five
percent a year by another eight percent
here and then all of a sudden boom this
has happened many many
how does it work with the board how many
members i don't know if we can find out
how many people are always an odd number
it's always an odd number so that you
know protect the voting so here you go
how many board members do they have one
two three four five six seven keep going
eight
nine uh ten
eleven a company this side is going to
be eleven okay yeah nine or eleven they
have eleven of them okay and how do you
become a board member to our company
like this or invited to
no it depends on what percentage you own
okay and if you buy in part of the
arrangement could be that you get under
the board seat but when you are
the largest shareholder now of twitter
tied with morgan stanley dean witter and
your name is elon musk
the guys that are in the board right now
want you to be also a board member
because they don't want you to do
anything reckless that's going to hurt
so now we want you in there as well it's
almost like a mutual thing where they
want both uh
uh to be in there but again i i i highly
doubt what tom just said right there i
think this is one of his next five 10 15
moves you know here's the other thing
too is a lot of these people are going
to be
opposed to elon musk just in general
they're not going to like him maybe
politically or or on some level but elon
just made everybody on that list a lot
of money yesterday did you see the
volume of trading it was six percent
well that's how hot that's how that was
the jump in the stock there was like 212
million you know shares sold and the
volume was 212 million as opposed to
like 1.5 million on friday so if the
stock goes up 25 he made everybody on
that board a lot richer so how can you
hate him that much so he's going to have
a lot more power once he starts buying
more more stock and what he owns 9.2
right now and that's just and it's just
tuesday right
and they know they know one tweet is
gonna get them so last night we're
having dinner okay one of the guys owns
the uh
one of the four most expensive cards in
the world right remember the guy on the
honest wagon or tt06 sgc5 is what it's a
25 million dollar card right guy who
eats at all the best restaurants the guy
that he's at the best restaurants then
another guy owned a couple 52 tops
mickey mantle which is like a five
million dollar card they're selling the
10 million dollar spider-man issue
number one uh i think it was great at
eight and a half which is pretty insane
there's only two nines in the world
they're selling that for 10 million
bucks so when you get into the card
community and you own a card that you
also own and you also own everybody here
wants that card to be valued more right
so for example one card is a mickey
mantle psa 10. you know it sold for 11
million dollars in 2017 right you know
what they're saying it's valued right
now the cheapest one you can buy right
now they're saying speculating obviously
that's what they're all saying 30
million dollars if you want to go on
that car today a mickey mantle 52 tops
right 30 million dollars wow so if
others do
own shares and tesla and you've got a
guy like ilan that can quadruple the
valuation of the company i think the
morgan stanley's and these other guys in
the world may say you know what
maybe it's a little bit more than
politics if you can increase our uh
valuation here elon go at it we'll let
you kind of you know since i haven't
been here in four months i've got to
maximize my time um i'm going to make
one more prediction and i feel very very
here about this one i think elon musk is
going to segue himself out of
joined the milwaukee bucks with giannis
as a free-throw coach no he's gonna he's
gonna work his way out of tesla within
the next year somehow some way i think
part of this is he's gonna have more fun
doing it he's going to be more
influential i think he's going to be
very very active with twitter and i just
don't think he's having fun with tesla
and i think he's going to find a way to
exit if it's at all possible if a guy
that big and that prominent in a company
can find a way out i think he will be
gone from tesla in a year i think we
need a new show tom zenner doubles as
miss cleo and we just have all his
predictions and we see what comes right
goes wrong you do love making
predictions
whether they're right or wrong or wrong
or wrong if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]